herzlich kommen zur zweiten folge von
ich fahre leute wir sind heute in köln
meiner aktuellen heimatstadt und es
trifft sich wirklich ausgezeichnet das
hier direkt neben mir
dave mit
[Musik]
habe ihm gaddafi
hallöchen was geht ab die in sein auto
wenn wir heute fahren du hast es fahren
danach wenn ich fand ja und ich hatte
erst mal vertrauen geredet dass was zu
sagen vielen vielen dank für die
einladung ich bin ich ja danke dass du
mitmachst überzeugt ich bin direkt rein
aber die warte mal lasst uns erst mal
kurzfristig um das auto herum schauen
wir haben mal ein bisschen gucken wie
deine zuschauer wissen und das sind ja
auch einige hast du den wagen mit
gamestop spekulationsgewinn wird seit
jahren die gelder für super sagt okay
was haben wir hier 2 518 zwei gut felgen
kann man jetzt hier bei tester nicht
erwarten über die maas muss man sagen
aber ja okay dass ich ein bisschen was
zum auto droppen was das genau für den
wagen ist jetzt sehen wir genau
also ich habe mich für einen tesla model
3 long range entschieden quasi dass das
auto mit der größten reichweite es gibt
drei versionen standard range long range
und performance das ein absolutes basic
modell eins für möglichst lange
reichweite und 1 eben für die maximale
performance meiner hat jetzt 460 ps als
long range ich dachte das würde mir
vermutlich reichen deswegen habe ich
mich dafür entschieden und nicht für die
super starke performance variante leute
manche stimmen munkeln dass ich auch
schon den wagen von marc gebauer
gefahren bin und dass der 450 ps hat und
richtig ab ging also 450 ps in den
benziner oder diesel sind schon eine
fette ansage beim auto ist auch krasse
also 44 70 bis 160 160 das ist schon das
ist eine hausnummer dafür darf man nicht
darf man nicht vergessen mit allrad ja
sehr geil ist geil wir haben hier eine
komplette durchgehende ja quasi glasdach
liegen hier das ist richtig das von
innen leute dann kommt man mit rein das
finde ich richtig geil was ich bei ihrem
1 max für man rein erstmal hier tür
vorgesehen
richtig geil und das krasse ist auch
dass man erst mal testen heute auch
richtig richtig geil so muss es sein
dass es wieder für euch kommt man hier
rum
ich darf mir hat ebenso oder lass ich
mal kurz aussteigen musste türgriff
jetzt nicht hier ist nichts das ist
nichts das schnee man drückt den knopf
und die tür geht auf
es gibt aber okay einen physischen tür
den sollte man aber nicht zu oft öffnen
bei der die fenster beschädigen kann es
so habe ich habe ich gesehen und wir
haben wir sehen hier interieur komplett
also jetzt ja gar nix nix das komplett
clean so minimalistisch einfach hier ist
auf fast gar nichts man muss sagen du
hast auch die letzten brocken geht
kriegt in kontakt zu diesem auto
gemieden kindern formal ja das ist
richtig leute ich hab ich hab mich
wirklich interessiert aber bei zwei
wochen einfach alles abgeblockt quasi
der hilfe so verbot mit mir darüber zu
reden damit bis heute erfahren und ich
würde sagen erfahren ist es auch
wirklich nur das stichwort jetzt oder ja
der rheinland let's go freue mich
tatsächlich sehr
in der runde mit dir zu fahren weil ich
weiß was du entziehen im blut hast du
aber ich hoffe halt ich hoffe dass ich
dich vielleicht auch von batteriesäure
in den wahrscheinlich die erste
besonderheit direkt beim ersten mal
anfangen dass er echt sei
okay das kann man gut er mach dir
vielleicht den motor an nein es gibt
keinen start stopp knopf der wagen ist
an sobald ich mich mit meinem handy in
vagen befinde das ist das finde ich
wirklich krass
das finde ich wirklich krass
normalerweise ich weiß nicht wenn so vw
oder sogar auszubauen haben wir noch ein
start stop ich habe keine ahnung ich
weiß das wird mich auch mal
interessieren weil das ja schon heftig
also vom gefühl her das ist aber auch
nur weil ich immer verbrenner gefallen
muss zudem autor sagen okay jetzt will
ich los fahren darfst du das gaspedal an
dem vorher nicht schluss ist einfach so
über im park rückwärtsgang oder drive
alt geregelt dass der merkt okay jetzt
möchte entwickle ich los von
grundsätzlich immer im park modus wenn
ich einsteiger und wenn ich dann fahren
will hier aber dass das tablet auch
richtig richtig neu ist es echt heftig
tiger aber die erste frage ist immer was
bedeutet es für dich
seit kurzem seit einem jahr ungefähr
tatsächlich hobby so hier und da mal
schauen welches auto kann was und videos
über autos schon vorher war es ein
absolut reines nutzer autos wirklich nur
für reine nutzen sachen reinkommen
gefahren
so war es immer mit meinen eltern ich
bin in einer familie groß geworden in
der autos wirklich keine große rolle
spielen und ist auch nie eingesehen
wurde viel geld für autos auszugeben
jetzt hat sich das ganz gut getroffen
mit dem aktiengewinnen und meiner meinem
steigenden interesse für autos dass ich
mich für den wagen entschieden habe aber
es ist noch nicht lang so und
mittlerweile ist es wirklich macht es
mir einfach spaß und ist ein hobby für
mich geworden ist auch dein erstes
eigenes auto genau also das ist ja
wirklich mal ein typisches kann
wir müssen 22 22 leute man kauft sich
ein erstes auto natürlich mit
spekulationsgewinnen aus aktien also das
wirklich der absolute standard und dann
direkt neuer tesla model 3 also alles
ganz normal so weit dazu vielleicht noch
einen satz deine eltern haben nicht wie
gesagt so erzogen
also ich kenne ja deine eltern auch die
sind komplett an tine hier aber die
könnten ganz andere autos fall als ich
tun aber fanden sehr sehr möglichst
wenig kosten und so hier mal tatsächlich
vermutet man das auf den ersten blick
nicht aber eigentlich ist das auch eine
philosophie die ich bei diesem auto
weitergeführt hat okay ich habe einen
sehr hohen anschaffungspreis der wagen
hat 52.000 euro gekostet wir jetzt hier
steht tatsächlich lerne ich bin aber
absolut kostenlos ich habe noch keinen
einzigen cent für auch nur einen
kilometer ausgegeben den ich gefahren
bin und der wagen wird super super stark
mit gefördert so dass er als
geschäftswagen extrem günstig ist die
steuerung ist extrem günstig und man
bekommt förderung wenn man den wagen
kauft bekommt man von der bafa mehrere
tausend euro zurück je nachdem was ich
finden und dann ist ja also jetzt bei
dem modell ja ich hab ich auch mal damit
auseinander gesetzt weil ich mir auch
überlegt mal drei zu holen kriegst du
glaube ich 3000 vom hersteller und 6000
vom bund oder sogenannte von euch mal
9000 euro auf 1 250 tausend euro auto
zurück plus steuerliche vergünstigungen
krasse die profis kennt sich damit aus
und du kannst auch noch sehr oft
kostenlos tanken
genau das ist schon krass es ist geplant
dass ich den wagen nach zwölf monaten
wieder abgebe weil sich der wertverlust
vom ersten jahr genau mit dem bonus
aufliegt okay was bedeuten würde wenn
ich den weiterhin für 0 euro tanke hat
der wagen mich für zwölf monate keinen
einzigen cent gekostet das ist krass
ausser die versicherung vielleicht würde
sagen
wenn du bereit bist dann kannst du auch
mal hier überziehen oder sondern wächst
man davon sehr gerne leute fahrerwechsel
bist du schon mal elektro auto gefahren
ich weiß ich irgendwann bauchgefühl sagt
mir mein kopf sagt ich kann mich nicht
erinnern okay aber vermutlich nicht so
nicht so im alltag ist das nicht so
häufig deswegen sage ich erst mal nichts
und du kannst einfach mal so losfahren
okay so jetzt bin ich gespannt bis jetzt
ein point ist der wagen fährt
tatsächlich den sitz zurück und das
lenkrad hoch damit ich einfacher
aussteigen kann das ist easy entry wenn
wir jetzt in den drive modus gehst dann
sollte der alles wieder in deine
richtung fangen ich wollte schon sagen
was ist das denn hier aber dass jetzt
das ist wie bei mercedes eigentlich ja
gang rechts am lenkrad genau also kleine
allerdings rückwärtsgang musste noch
irgendwas einstellen lenkrad spiegelte
das alles ist das passt alles wunderbar
ok komischer mal was ich von automatik
autos kenne
du hast rückwärtsgang drin du gehst von
der bremse runterfährt nicht von selbst
ist einfach nur ein sehr anderes
fahrgefühl vor allem auch das
geradeausfahren
herr ich erwarte die ganze zeit so dass
das auto oft auf meinen gasbefehl auf
die neigung im fuß halt so wenn wir mehr
aber das aber so das ist wie ein
simulator
ich finde und das was ich dir nicht
gesagt habe ist was du wahrscheinlich
relativ stark merkst wenn du vom gas
geht ist die rekuperation die motoren
ist ja nicht motorbremse oder vielleicht
irgendwie schon aber ja der ist wirklich
so als wenn er beim normalen beim
benziner vom gas geht dann ist also aber
hier so genau also rekuperation was so
ziemlich jedes elektroauto hat bedeutet
einfach dass die die energie die das
rollende fahrzeug noch harten wieder
zurück umgewandelt wird um die batterie
wieder aufzuladen quasi das ist einer
der gründe warum dieses auto super super
wenig verschleiß hat ich bremse mit dem
auto kann ich wahrscheinlich wirklich an
einer hand abzählen wie oft ich die
bremse in diesem auto benutzt habe wenn
man vorausschauend fährt benutzt man
quasi nur die rekuperation um das auto
zum stehen zu bringen leute ich habe
auch nicht auch auf den tacho okay ich
weiß x 440 sachen und ich geh jetzt mal
vom gas ich drücke nicht die bremse
jetzt
ist zum stillstand das ist ja nicht das
ist ja wie sanftes bis mittleres bremsen
im auto also ein ganz wichtiges thema
aber den autos du dich mal die
beschleunigung ist gefahr seine reise
gibt keinen lounge konferenz gehe man
auf die bremse drauf kann ich brems und
gleichzeitig einfach komplett durch
treten
ich bin richtig gespannt degas erstes
twitter und im tesla ich hatte noch nie
das ist vor ihr drückt mir jetzt noch
mal durch aus den räumen auf die katze
so etwas war wie krass sehr sagen das
gefühl voll wir also bei benzin
verbrennt denkmal so ok aus dem stand
also unterbrechung dazwischen bei den
gang wechseln wie nochmal ich glaube es
war ja wenn ich mich jetzt richtig nicht
täuscht und hier ist einfach so ja ok
leistung ist da wenn du darauf tritt
also das ist wirklich wie in der
achterbahn leute und ihr seid unten und
in so eine achterbahn wohl so hoch
geschossen werden und auf einmal kommt
der schlag in nacken und ich finde man
merkt auch wirklich dass das auto und
super niedrigen schwerpunkt hat dadurch
dass die batterien hier überall im boden
liegen lenkung ist interessant ist
wirklich interessant ist wie kohle die
relativ direkt finde ich aber warum
kriegt er aus dem stand nicht so rein
wie aus dem dings ja das ist ich kann
sie nicht sagen um durchdrehenden reifen
zu veränderungen und was auch am antrieb
zu schonen oder so aber max tut mir leid
da hinten mit der kamera weil du
versuchst viel kamera gehalten
aber woran ich noch denken muss ist so
socal hallo du wirst prinzessin leia ich
bin han solo und max instructor und wir
sind einfach millennium falcon und in
dem moment wo du so dass so fühlt sich
das an
wohin also fängt wirklich an so an der
seite vorbei
bisher ist ja richtig krass alter auch
keine schaltvorgänge ja genau das ist
das wirklich so ok den abi mich in der
welt kommt uns die mich einfach los und
das sind kombinationen mit der technik
und dem minimalismus ist halt schon
wirklich sehr eigenes gefühl auf jeden
fall ab gesprächs das auto hat er voll
abgespeist und manövrieren von ungewohnt
das lenkrad schlägt ist voll frühen wir
am ende
so ein einer umdrehung ins schluss eine
unterrichtung eine umdrehung in jeder
voll krass dass das ist für das
komplette feeling rate ich dir den erst
rekuperieren zu lassen und dann rein zu
treten
okay weil deshalb den extra bus genau
weil er bremst um dann über schleunigst
du aus der bremsung ok warte heraus
mein gott da ist dass gta automarkt es
eben geht ja strandparty einfach mit
lüneburger kennzeichen was macht den
keller weil das weil google apps
angesprochen hast es ist tatsächlich so
dass immer mal wieder software updates
kommen ich habe gerade eben auch wieder
1 installiert das ist halt super
verrückten auto zu haben was sich über
die zeit noch wirklich verändert was
neue features bekommt und das ist echt
krass ja was sich wirklich verbessert
bei anderen autos habe ich immer so ein
bisschen das gefühl das auto bleibt
entweder stehen oder es wird sogar über
die zeit er ein bisschen schlechter wird
als schon aus dass es altert aber ein
auto zu haben das zu einem großteil auf
software basiert ist mittlerweile halt
ein riesenvorteil wirklich wirklich geil
das ist also dieses iphone update ist
dass über nacht oder weiß nicht wie
schnell das geht und das nächste mal
machst du auch nicht hoffen natürlich
ganz anders sein
genau anderes handy aber eine sache die
mich direkt ein bisschen stört das macht
bmw aber auch ist dass der blinker nicht
feststeht in die richtung wo du hin wie
ja das nervt also wenn du nach rechts
leute macht oben nach rechts dann fällt
er zurück und blinkt dann nur weiter man
kann es nicht zu erfüllen wo du stehst
du musst einfach links machen dann aber
geil und viel mehr als ein ipad der gala
er kennt die ampeln erkennt die
radfahrer erkennt fußgänger erkennt die
autos und ist so halt super super
intuitiv was das angeht also es ist
schon viel über gas geben und bremsen
mögliche geredet aber das eigentlich
also das herzstück hier passiert
eigentlich alles was kannst du mir noch
so zeigen an dem auto ich habe vorne der
ssd verbaut die alle vier kameras
durchgehend aufnehmen lässt wenn ich
hupe wird automatisch jeder kamerawinkel
der letzten zehn minuten ab gespeichert
so dass sich
tränen situationen oder fast unfälle
oder unfälle immer auf kamera ab wie
geil das tablet oder das auto hat eine
erste main gebaut wir haben die ganze
zeit streamen wir die ganzen songs des
trainings vor gespeichert weil natürlich
kein physisches medium hier drin wo die
sachen gespeichert sind sondern das ist
mit meinem spotify connected ist mit
meinem youtube connect hat netflix which
das ist kann das auto alles das kann ich
dir gleich vielleicht zeigen wollen wir
mal stehen es gibt games die du mit dem
lenkrad dem gaspedal und den bremsen
spielst also was rennspiele es gibt
super viele kleine features wie graf es
gibt ein musikprogramm mit dem du ein
paar beats zusammenbauen kannst es ist
wirklich eine menge zu entdecken wie
krass alter was mich sehr beeindruckt
hat ist wie die wie man den luftstrom
hier steuern kann
ich merke das richtige gesicht immer du
kannst genauer steuern wo das hingehen
soll du kannst es an dir vorbei splitten
du kannst das für den beifahrer auch
noch mal machen hier vorne haben wir
kontaktloses laden wir haben über usb
ports verbaut die genug spannung
ausgeben um auch ein macbook zu laden
super super viele kleine gimmicks die
diesen die dieses den rahmen von dem
video jetzt einfach komplett sprengen
würde wenn ich das jetzt alles erklären
will
mega mega geil wissen was mein eindruck
ist ich denke mit diesem auto was haben
die alle autohersteller die ganze zeit
gemacht ja die also das ist so als hätte
einer mal so gesagt ey was macht ihr so
wie könnt ihr alle geiler machen so klar
der kann dies kann der kann keine
motoren bauen also keine verbrenner
motoren der elan aber warum sowas nich
einem audi oder vw
wie war es eigentlich für dich jetzt du
bist eine weile ihr auto gefahren hatte
da etwas gefehlt oder bis letzte woche
war das auto für mich eine 10 aus 10
das war super zufrieden hatte keine
probleme hat überall in der stadt
kostenlos geladen mich kostenlos auf
irgend welche parkplätze gestellt weil
man super viele vorzüge hat dann bin ich
letzte woche zum ersten mal langstrecke
gefahren richtung stuttgart und ich habe
wirklich eine chance nach der anderen
erlebt wenn zum super charger gefahren
das system hat mich hin navigiert komme
an und das super jokers außer betrieb
36 kilometer reichweite war es halt
nicht so dass du ein benzinkanister
hinbringt und damit dann zur nächsten
tanke kommst oder hier kannst du keine
power bank anstecken oder soja sondern
du musst dich abschleppen lassen wenn es
einmal rum ist
und dann musste ich mir den weg suchen
und habe an einem destination charger
heißen die ein super langsamer 11 kw
ladegerät da den tesla dran gehangen
musste anderthalb stunden laden bissig
genug reichweite hatte um zum nächsten
super charger angolas genau wo ich dann
langen ladenkonzept krass und es war ein
bisschen mein fehler ich hätte in der
app sehen können dass das super dazu ist
aber das navi hat mich hin geführt da
habe ich dann schon gemerkt okay das ist
vielleicht dann doch vorteil von einem
benziner von einem diesel wo man immer
auf fossile brennstoffe zurückgreifen
können achtung kurzer clip
ok so ab 130 ab 130 kamera wird
bewältigbar untenrum ist es wirklich ist
mein gott oh mein gott aber ab 130 ist
so ok jetzt können wir so langsam wieder
kann ich im kopf wieder von der
heckschürze nehmen genau aber man kann
trotzdem noch ganz entspannt überholen
und dann bedeutet kommen wir zu bewerten
die bewährten findet in sechs kategorien
stadt aussehen beschleunigung coolness
praktikabilität also wie praktisch das
auto ist preis leistung und komfort für
meine bewertung des aussehens werde ich
eventuell ein bisschen hält bekommen
oder allgemein für diese bewertung ein
bisschen hält bekommen ich find das
tesla model 3 nicht schön
ich finde die proportionen von diesem
auto sind nicht besonders toll sind
nicht so gut geraten es ist einfach in
meinen augen kein schönes auto auf die
gefallen das hat mir den kopf abreißt
zwei von fünf die beschleunigung ist ein
richtiges highlight der tesla ist sofort
da sobald man das gaspedal drückt da
wird keinen druck aufgebaut gar nix und
drückten dem kopf in die stütze
allerdings ab 130 nicht mehr so vehement
vier von fünf kunden das was die technik
angeht die technischen features und
spielereien in diesem auto müsste ich
eigentlich eine 5 von 5 für die coolness
geben dazu profitiert das model 3 auch
von der coolness von elias dem gründer
und geschäftsführer von tesla aber aber
weil ich mich einfach mit der optik
nicht so anfreunden kann und die
bewertung auch im vergleich zb mit lukas
9 und 2 turbo s der vier von fünf
bekommen hat noch fair sein muss und
passen muss gibt's hier drei von fünf
die praktikabilität ist eigentlich top
mann hat eine ganze menge platz man hat
hinten den kofferraum sogar von frank
also front kofferraum allerdings wird
das ganze gedrückt durch das problem
dass unternehmen auch dave geschildert
hat dass man einfach im ernstfall sich
abschleppen lassen muss wenn man leer
läuft und einfach mehr planen muss noch
als man verbrennt zumindest aktuell was
auch nicht komplett die schuld des autos
ist aber es ist halt so
drei von fünf was das preis
leistungsverhältnis angeht bin ich
wirklich sehr sehr sehr beeindruckt von
dem autodata 250 tausend euro bezahlt
bekommt davon noch 9000 euro bonus
abgezogen hat viele vergünstigungen und
für den preis ist das einfach eine
hammer angebot vier von fünf jahre beim
komfort bislang registriert ich fand das
auto war durchaus komfortabel allerdings
jetzt auch nicht viel mehr komfortabler
als zum beispiel ein vw golf ist ich tue
mich wirklich schwer damit die gleiche
bewertung wie lukas 911 turbo s zu geben
aber ich habe mich stand jetzt dagegen
entschieden halbe punkte zu vergeben
weil es einfach scheiße aussieht es ist
eine gefühlte 3,5 von fünf aber ich gehe
mit 35
insgesamt kommen wir damit auf 19 von 30
punkten ein kleines stückchen unter
lukas porsche der mit 21 von 30 punkten
ein bisschen höher abgeschnitten hat ich
freue mich riesig auf das nächste auto
nächste folge kommt nächsten sonntag
leute und jetzt im laufe der woche
kommen top videos mit dave also bis
dahin macht's gut